most of the reason i'm talking to you
today is for mr robot
uh and i loved the series so much and
i'm so
happy that we are finally gonna do like
a deep dive conversation
um but i do have some questions on some
other things so rather than
just diving into mr robot which is going
to take a long time in my opinion
uh i want to throw out some other things
um
what tv series would you love to guest
write and direct
wow um
that's so interesting because you know
the first thing that comes to mind
are the you know the i feel like they're
the easy answers like twilight zone and
black mirror
because they're standalone episodes
but i feel like i feel like to give you
a more interesting answer it would be to
like
jump into a show like atlanta but
i would never be able to be good enough
to do anything remotely close as those
those guys uh what they what they do on
that show
um so i think i might have to go
with something
totally out of left field like penn 15
just because i think i think those two
leads are so great
that those two actresses are so amazing
and i would love to just
i think it would just be fun to just
watch them
uh watch perform they're so hilarious i
love that show
if you could get the financing tomorrow
for anything that you want to make
what would you make and why jesus
uh you are not coming with the softball
questions huh um
[Laughter]
wow i mean that's a tough one
uh i have a project that i
but it's pretty ambitious and i haven't
i haven't finished writing it
and i really don't want to get into it
that much but it's a pretty
heady sci-fi extravaganza
but it's it's really
dense it's r-rated it's like there's a
million reasons why it's not
commercially viable at
all um but it's a but it
it to me is is going to be that that one
moby dick project that that great that
great whale that i'm going to be
uh wanting to launch off the ground for
my the rest of my career i feel like
that's the one that's gonna put me in my
grave
so it'll be that one i actually think
this is the perfect time
to be doing something ambitious and cool
and out there because
everyone's looking for cool content so
if you have a great script and there are
stars that like want to be in it i i
actually think it's a good time i mean
you gotta you gotta realize i mean if
we're gonna get into it it's the
theatrical model
is what concerns me you're right to say
that
um perhaps there it'd be um easier
to to get it straight to streaming but
the the movie i'm picturing really
deserves to
uh be on the big screen and that's the
tricky part
because especially given with what
happened in the past year
i think studios are going to be a little
more gun shy to jump
into an expensive original
uh sci-fi film but hey man i i hope
you're i hope i'm wrong and you're right
listen i think we're going to know a lot
more with uh dune
uh later this year but even that was
based on a
very popular book you know what i mean
sure but unfortunately i think there's a
i think
the majority of people that are going to
go see dune like 98
of them don't know what dune is dune is
have never read the book
they're going to go because of zendaya
and timothy and it's cool and it's new
and
like if that film doesn't work with
with what's going on then it's a really
bad thing for the marketplace
that's very true and i'm crossing my
fingers because i
it looks amazing and denis villanova is
you know he's one of the if not the best
you know filmmaker out there right now
doing popcorn entertainment at extremely
high level so
yeah i agree he's operating on another
existence and what he did with blade
runner 2049 doesn't make sense
that they let him do what he did with
that yeah i totally agree
um but yeah he's he's doing it and
he's pulling it off and he's not uh
what's great about him is that he's not
really compromising
i mean i don't think he's i'm sure he's
been offered every superhero
under the sun he hasn't done that he's
done remakes sure
but honestly he keeps it pretty
much in his tone and his voice and he's
doing it
see this is the thing and this is why i
was talking about the the rating the r
rating of the
the script that i was trying to make is
that adult
sci-fi seems to get lost in the
in the shuffle when it comes to uh
theatrical because you know rightfully
so i understand the business the
economics of
what the studios are trying to do is
when they put money a lot of money into
it
it really needs to be family friendly
but when you're going into it with like
heady themes
uh it's just a bigger gamble for
everyone involved and i think villanov
is one of those guys that you know a lot
of a lot of
a lot of the studio system has a lot of
faith in that guy because
he does it really well and you know at
an exceptionally high level
his movies are going to are going to
stay in the test time which leads me to
my next thing
i read when you were growing up that you
were a huge kubrick fan
um and i'm curious if you could talk
about how
kubrick possibly influenced mr robot or
little homages that you wanted to put
into mr robot to reference kubrick
well i think kubrick is it for me when
it comes to filmmakers
i obviously have other favorite
filmmakers but
um i mean if you take
what kubrick did and the way i was
introduced to kubrick was
in high school i you know i i had never
heard of him i'd never seen any of his
films and in fact i wanted to be a
filmmaker at that point
but i was really more driven by
uh the more popcorn films that i'd loved
as a kid
you know back to the future being like
sort of
the apex of that mountain well those are
the type of movies i was
thinking about doing and uh thinking
about wanting to make
uh for myself and and and then i was
invited by a
a friend of mine to watch to do
he was gonna throw a kubrick film
festival that we would watch all
not all of his movies but i think five
or six of his movies but
obviously all the all the all the the
top ones that you would
think of 2001 clockwork orange um
strange love and i was just
blown away i mean when you watch
something like 2001 for the first time
uh it just and i still
will say this even though there have
been a ton of movies made since then
it just stands on its own as an ex
it's an experience it's almost weirdly
um
because i was so fixated with
storytelling and with back to the future
specifically and that script it's so
perfect it's been talked about ad
nauseam
about how perfect that screenplay is
every setup has a payoff
every detail um connects to something
um and this and the and the sort of
characterizations and the
and the beats and all the moves that
they make are so smart
um and and have such richness and in
depth
but then you get to 2001 and it's not
it sort of takes the storybook the
storytelling
roles and just tosses it out the window
i don't even know if you call it a story
it feels like an essay to me but it's an
experience
it's it's a transcendent sort of
i am going to suck you in and transport
you
into a whole other dimension
of reality that um that we can create
with our cameras here on earth
um and that's how special it felt to me
that's how deep it sort of penetrated my
soul
and and how and the little filmmaker me
back then
um how it sort of revolutionized how i
even thought about film because it
wasn't
just about telling a story it was about
so much more than that it was about
tone it was about um spectacle
it was about music um
all of these things it just uh
and so so just your larger question
about kubrick
every one of his films he has this sort
of
way in that defies
the logic of storytelling but but but
where he's not just wanting to tell you
the beats of how a character gets from
point a to point b
but he wants to share the meaning of
life with you
simultaneously and he pulls it off
and weirdly pulls it off in
all different genres i mean this
[ __ ] went did
satires comedies sci-fi
uh historical drama um uh
a romantic drama i mean he it was almost
like he was
testing himself a war film i mean he
never uh he was always surprising i mean
there a lot of my favorite filmmakers
they have a thing right they have their
their lane that they're good at right
and and
they're exceptionally good and i don't
want them to veer off the path like
like give me what you're good at and i
enjoy it and
and you know challenge yourself in with
within that um
uh within your strengths but it's almost
like nothing
nothing could um nothing could touch
kubrick and so
for me he's like mount rushmore but he's
all the faces
you know what i mean like i i wouldn't i
i really it's
i struggled to think who i could put on
that tier and so
um and so when i went into wanting to do
my own
uh my own stuff started to write my own
scripts
again when you go through film school or
or just even when you pick up a
book at the at the bookstore like i did
about how to make a movie or how to test
like they really really really focus on
the storytelling
which is incredibly important and it is
the bedrock i i i totally
i i don't i don't want to i don't want
to um sound like i'm
i'm dissuading uh uh anyone from
thinking that i i
i i don't find value in storytelling but
there is
so much more on top of that you know
when i got into tv
tv was considered the writer's media and
it was all about the story
and the only thing the director was
really trained to do in tv back in the
day
was really document what was on the page
in fact to the to a certain
dictatorial extent some of the
showrunners would really
make sure that the directors had every
line of dialogue captured on camera
so that they could put it together and
uh in post but because
we're dealing with a visual medium there
are so many other layers
on top of that and i think that's what
kubrick
did to the medium that i had never quite
uh felt before uh i saw anything and so
that's what i strive for
and even when i jumped into tv that's
what i was doing
even from like just a writer's room
perspective we would talk about how
we're going to film it
because i just find that there are when
once you start getting into that
stratosphere there are so many more
layers and so many more
uh interesting concepts and things you
can dig
into that's not just about a character
and their journey i completely agree and
get with what you're saying
so i have to ask do you think anyone at
any point in the future is going to make
the napoleon script
and if it was offered and if it was
offered to you and they said you can
make napoleon and use kubrick's script
would you do it i
i no no i would not i i i
i um that's just setting myself up to
fail i i mean again then
we're talking about uh the king of all
kings in terms of filmmakers and that
i'm not gonna come close to that but
besides i think
one of the great things about kubrick
and this is another thing that inspires
me
of him is that he knows what he's even
though he
hopped around in different genres he
knows what he's
he he had something about each story
obviously penetrated him you could still
tell it's a kubrick film
even though you're laughing instead of
being in a horror film like the shining
um there was still a connective tissue a
connective tone
to all of his work um and and i think
that came from the fact that he
felt a deep connection to every story
and that's that's been a guiding
principle that i
that i try and hold on to so napoleon i
i don't think
you know uh hits me in the same way that
hit kubrick so
you know for that reason alone i i
wouldn't touch it but of course
again probably wouldn't come come close
to what kubrick would have done anyway
so
yeah i'll pass
uh i'm really looking forward to a
project you're doing with your wife
uh angeline um when will
we be seeing the i don't know how many
episodes is it is it a movie is it
episode
it's a limited series um and you know
we're shut down
uh because of covid and as you know la's
numbers just keep getting worse and
worse
uh it is a very los angeles show
you know we there's no really no way to
excuse me there's really no way to
travel with the show uh we it's
it's pretty uh uh uniquely uh set
in los angeles and in certain time
periods in los angeles
um so uh we're just honestly we're just
waiting for
the the numbers to get better to get
back into production we're about
you know halfway through it maybe maybe
a third of the way through it
so we still got a lot a lot a lot to
shoot i read and i could be wrong that
you were involved in some sort of
metropolis
is that the case it is the case um
i'm working on the pilot as we speak i'm
pretty excited about it
again i'm not going to get into too many
details
uh but i will say i think i think uh i
think we'll there
will be some news coming out on that
soon we're getting closer to mr robot
but look
i think you have a netflix movie with
denzel and julia that is
in development what's the status of that
are you filming that this year yeah the
goal is to shoot that sometime
later later this year so you have the
script done and everything
i do i do have a a draft done and
um yeah we'll see how it goes i'm now
opening the door on mr robot
which is going to take some serious time
so take a
take get a glass of uh water take a sip
are you ready i think i'm ready i think
i'm good i'll just do it
um so uh jumping into mr robot um do you
i for people that aren't familiar i
believe you came up with this
originally as a feature you were
thinking about this as a movie
so can you sort of talk about the
genesis of where the idea came from
and uh let's start with that yeah so
uh you know growing up i was a huge
computer nerd um i mean i was probably
on the internet before
and anybody i knew i i any of my friends
were because we would steal the internet
from our local
uh our local college which happened to
be rowan college now rowan university
but back then it was all text-based
internet this is prior to
browsers and so i was really entrenched
in that world and i always found the
people in that world really fascinating
and in the early days with bbs's and
and irc chats and all that you just meet
a lot of wacky people
and it start but but they but there was
something there was something really
special about the way they saw the world
and
um and and then you know a lot of my
friends ended up uh
also being really into computers so as a
filmmaker
i always knew okay this is a world i
think is really interesting and it just
stuck
with me growing up that i got i gotta i
gotta tell a story about this world
because the other thing was is that
you know when you watch these you know
back in the 90s or
or in the 2000s you know movies about
hackers
or or television shows about hackers sad
to say we're not
not that great um and and they really
kind of missed the point they would
really
talk about hacking by throwing bad cgi
at you
and and really not talk about the
essence of what hacking is which is
actually not just a personality keyboard
but really it's about social engineering
and getting to
and getting to the uh exploiting the
flaws in people
and the systems that people create which
i always found fascinating
so that was like thing number one
thing number two was 2008
financial crash after eight
you know pretty terrible years with
george w bush
and i i just remember the rage
i felt along with i think the rest of
the country uh that's when the occupy
wall street
uh movement happened and um
and i just and that all sort of
overlapped with all the
all the hackers that i knew and all the
programs that i knew uh
who were sort of you know uh
anti-corporate
uh had the anti-corporate mentality
anyway but the financial crash
sort of confirmed all their suspicions i
mean
uh uh the the top one percent
finally became sort of like a bad name
around that i don't think that was a
thing but prior to then
you know but then it was very clear who
the villains were in 2008 there was like
no
no uh no question about it and so
that thing number two was like oh i have
my villain
i i found my villain like you know
there's that hacker story that i
always wanted to tell and here's like
the perfect villain
um and then thing number three was it
was
arabs was the arab spring which happened
a few years after that
and you know i'm egyptian and i just
remember
watching it with my father uh when they
you know
uh uh when they took down mubarak and
and these kids and they were all young
and using the internet
and using social media to organize
and form this revolution where otherwise
they wouldn't have ever
been able to do that they wouldn't have
been able to like organize in such a
mass way that they've
that uh that they did and so
i was so moved by that that was that was
sort of the
third piece of that puzzle where i said
okay i've got my villain i've got my
world
and my character in that world and now i
have
like the journey which is revolution the
journey which is to
you know if you are so disillusioned
with the world around you
can you use the tools at your disposal
to change the world around you
and that's how that's sort of what drove
me to write
to write to start writing or thinking
about that feature when you went into
usa network to pitch
how much in the room did you tell them
like the overarching everything how much
did you
know how much did they want to know uh
back then that you had like a four
season plan or a
multi-season plan yeah no i i uh they
they knew that i had uh uh uh
i i would always say four to five
seasons because i didn't know
specifically i was like
it's roughly four to five seasons and
that i have an ending
and then i i think i would always say
but if i told you the ending it probably
wouldn't make sense right now
and i also didn't want to share the
ending i mean i didn't
tell the ending i think i told rami
maybe between seasons two and three and
then i started opening up
to some of the other cast members during
season three
but i was just paranoid that it was
going to get out i thought people were
going to figure it out
anyway and and to a certain extent i
started not mine
but i mean you know i had a lot of
paranoia i mean i think emmy at one
point was pissed that i wasn't telling
her
i mean that's how bad that's how
paranoid
that that's how paranoid i was so uh so
i didn't
but wouldn't it but isn't it almost
better like i'm a fan of the series
and i didn't want to know anything until
you know i saw it in the show
yeah no i i agree i think when you're in
it and you're making it
and you're also so curious i think
i think it's just one of those things
that people can't help themselves and
um and and they also i think a lot of
people are are kind of curious man
you're really
building up to this thing what if it's
not that great
you know like you're really holding on
to this thing i mean it's been three
years sam you sure
that's the ending you want to stick with
so like i think that everyone was sort
of fishing
kind of kicking the tires at the same
time you know um
and uh but but yeah so to go back to
your question so when i pitched it
by the way you know you were not
expected to know the ending because i
didn't
know especially we're talking 2014
the mindset wasn't due for
four or five seasons and get off the air
the mindset was
get on the air and stay on the air as
long as [ __ ] possible you know what i
mean
like that was the mindset so i don't
think they were that interested
early on i don't think anybody was that
interested early on
how it's going to end because in success
i think everybody just assumed
well i'm not going to actually stick to
the four to five season that i'll just
go for as long as as long as uh we're
cr you know we're interested in telling
the story and that that people are into
it
um but no i i i i
eventually ended up telling the network
uh again i think probably around season
three
um and uh and you know they tried to
convince me not to end it
not not because they weren't supportive
because i gotta say
you know above anything all ucp my
studio
and usa have been massively supportive i
mean you saw what we did on the show
it's just a lot of risks uh a lot of big
swings we took
and they were one thousand percent
behind me behind me on every decision
but the decision but it was you know
they were such fans of the show they
didn't
want it to end as as as early as i
ended it um but obviously eventually
they
they supported because i knew it was it
was uh
creatively the right thing to do the
first season
was 10 episodes the second season was
12 third season 10 fourth season 13.
how did you end up with those how did
you end up with 12 in the second season
and then
13 in the fourth what were these your
choices was this
the network yeah it's it's a little bit
like the battle star model
which is um we just
we just went in the writers room and we
were
again because i knew where we were going
we would put up
what the ending of the season was we put
up what the beginning of the season was
and what is the most organic way to get
from point a to point b
there was never a moment in the room
where we were like okay so we need to
fill 10 episodes how do we do that
we didn't even think about episode count
we literally
just thought about story we thought
about character
and we thought about what was organic
like we didn't want to skip any beats
so for example in season two because i
got more immersed and more involved
it ended up being longer same thing with
season four
season ten was a lot faster and you know
uh
uh a lot of the plot machinations
required the characters not to really
think or dwell on the choices or
decisions because they didn't really
have the time to we put
but put everybody kind of under a lot of
pressure
so so so there were less episodes but
ultimately
we an episode count was never in our
minds when we went up
into the writer's room in fact that's
how i determined season four
was the last season because after season
three
we went into the room for season four
thinking still
there were going to be five seasons
because again i always said four to five
everybody always just took the higher
number because they wanted the show to
keep going
and so um so we would go in the room we
would start talking
and i was like guys i start i started to
feel that feeling
of where we're treading water here we're
we're trying to fill up a season and i'm
like let's just
let's just stop let's let me put because
i
i always knew what the last two episodes
were but let's throw that up
on the on the board here's where we are
from
from the ending of season three how many
episodes is that
and so we broke that and i still didn't
know i didn't know if it was going to be
end up being 18
in which case okay fine there would be
two seasons i didn't know if it was
going to be like a
like a 13 where you could still kind of
break it up into two seasons i don't
know i kind of let
usa make that call but ultimately i just
found the number
the right number for the story that we
were trying to tell
we shared it with the network and uh and
then we
we called it the last season you guys
always got such great reviews every
season
after the first season when everyone's
talking about it
um did you feel any sort of internal
pressure
on season two three and four because the
reviews were so strong and the fan
reaction was so strong
did it ever get internalized or were you
sort of like i got this i know the story
i wanted to
well it was a little bit of both i i i
remember feeling like i got this
i know the story i want to tell but
because of the strong reception of the
first season
i didn't know if that was the story
people wanted
to see you know what i mean because i
wasn't going to do because typically
i think in a lot of tv shows you would
just assume elliott would do some more
hacking stuff and take down another
thing in the second season
another thing in the third season uh and
i knew that that wasn't what we were
gonna do that this was
going to be this gradual uh
uh sort of long game to uh to that to
that final
final two or three episodes that i
always had in mind
and so there were and there were going
to be a it's going to be a very
different show every season
because of that because we were
continuing down this
uh this path so i was i was nervous and
rightfully so i think because the
seasons ended up feeling a lot of
feeling very different from one another
i think people have very strong
reactions
especially the second season which i
always say is my favorite season
but it's the most internal season
because that's the to me that that was
the season where i really wanted to
isolate elliott
and have him face the reality of his
condition um
very different than the first season
which was more of this propulsive
thriller-like
uh storyline so um i think i think
uh i think i was both feeling a little
pressure because curious if people were
gonna
be into a show that changes so much from
season to season
but at the same time i ultimately knew
that was the only way i was gonna tell
the story was
i wasn't gonna like pull punches on that
i wasn't gonna just
just have him repeat the same thing
every year that he had to
progress and get towards that end game
during the process
i would imagine you had ideas and then
as you're going
like things you know obviously happen
were there any big changes that happened
along the way that you were really
surprised at
um i don't i don't think so i mean
honestly uh i had a
i i i i hate to say this because i've
heard the horror stories on other shows
and
um but our our cast and crew
was like a big family i've never heard
that before
well yeah you're right that's even a
cliche but i gotta be honest with you it
is
it is sort of very true in in that
everyone
felt uh everyone felt like we were doing
this very special thing
from the beginning i mean even christian
who you know
i was a huge fan of his back in high
school and
pump up the volume was like on vhs i
played it like constantly
along with true romance and heathers and
um
and i remember the first couple of
episodes in season one when it started
airing
he turned to me and he said this has
never happened to me before
like i've never been in anything where
this has had
the reception and the and the way where
people were feeling about
the show but also the way we were
feeling about what we were making
he was telling me he never felt that way
before
the guy's been in incredible movies and
has had this like illustrious career
and he's telling me that and i don't
know any better because this is
basically after a comment this is
literally the only job i've ever had and
um
and that that stayed true throughout all
four seasons that never
wavered or changed uh uh and so i
i yeah i i don't i can't say there were
any big surprises
uh i want to talk to you about the fact
of all the writing and directing that
you did because i believe in the first
season you did a few episodes
and then season two on you directed
everything um for people that are not
aware
when you're making a television show um
directing one episode
is obviously a challenge because you're
directing but meanwhile
another team is usually prepping the
next episode or they're prepping
too ahead so i have to ask how the f
did you pull off directing all these
episodes because i know what goes on
behind the scenes
in trying to bring this to life well
first of all i would not recommend it
i would i would probably never do it
quite in this way again like that uh i
think
i think it's it's very taxing
it's very very uh i mean you're
absolutely right
it's a hundred some days to direct the
entire season
and you know when a movie gets a hundred
days
uh that's one thing because they're
shooting a 120 page script
i'm shooting 13 episodes and each of
those episodes are
roughly you know anywhere from 48
minutes to an hour
uh and there's different characters and
different storylines
and not only that i'm doing it all out
of order so i could be shooting
scenes from the finale on day one of
production
um and then the second day i'm jumping
to episode four
so it's a lot to get in your head i
think the only reason why i was able to
do it was because
i was a showrunner and i intimately knew
the story more than anybody else um so i
was able to kind of keep track on the
track
on it but i also just had an incredible
i mean
again i hate to sound like a cliched
[ __ ] but
i had an amazing executive producer uh
chad hamilton and kyle bradstreet uh who
are
amazing partners throughout every season
um
and you know and i had an amazing cast
and crew that was
uh you know my dp uh my my uh todd
campbell my production designer
anastasia why i got i got it
i got to do a shout out to all them cat
thomas my costumes these people were
filmmakers there are filmmakers and they
they they sort of lifted up ever you
know you
they can't you know you can't ask these
department heads
to do what they do uh like like they
would on a net regular film where i'm
the god and
you know they just do what i say because
of the sort of
uh uh the the the huge uh uh
undertaking we were go we were uh uh
tackling
they had to step up and be filmmakers
with me um so that's why
you know weirdly i i it was a very
collective experience even though i was
the one director
across the entire season i leaned on
my uh my my team a lot to make sure that
we were able to like cross the finish
line every year and then of course after
every season
i wanted to pass out but i couldn't
because the very next day
i was in the writers room for the next
season it was it was pretty brutal
a lot of filmmakers i speak to talk
about how when they're shooting a movie
they're working such intense hours that
they can't believe it
and as soon as the movie wraps they get
ridiculously sick
because they have pushed their body as
far as it can humanly go
did that happen with you after every
season yes
and but the thing the thing i mean yeah
the answer is yes
you what you do is you just you your
body start
fatigue really starts to set in
everything starts to feel
just more exhausting just walking just
getting up out of bed every morning
it just starts to it just starts to
really wear on your body it's it's not a
look it's not a healthy thing which is
why i'm advising filmmakers
do not do what i'm doing i mean the
thing is you know
when i think about like what carrie did
on true detective
or even you know my experience on
homecoming
to do a season of a show
and and then to say and then to take a
break and
and go to sleep for a while or you know
edit the thing and take a break
before you that's one thing but what i
was doing
was because it's because it's you know
cable
it's like the minute i rap i gotta go
right back into
the next c they don't they don't care
they want the next season to come on
you know roughly around the same time
the following year and we would push a
little bit
because they didn't want to completely
murder me um
but it was still it was just still a
train that just did not stop
moving and that that's the that's
probably the unhealthy part
uh so i'm assuming that you had all the
scripts
of all the episodes done prior to
filming the first episode
yes so that always happened in season
two three and four correct
it was it was after then to me
weirdly even though i didn't direct all
the episodes in the first season
that was probably the worst experience
for me
because that wasn't the case
i was i had most of the episodes done by
the time we started shooting
but i was still kind of working on the
last
two or three episodes and i was
rewriting i wrote the last two episodes
and
so i was rewriting them and working them
while i was on set and had my laptop on
there
and it just to me was just not uh
i i just didn't understand that from a
mental from my mentality
that once once i i need to write
and then once i'm done writing i need to
then go into production mode and then
translate
what's on the page onto the screen and
then once i'm done
shooting then i can go into the other
bay and then translate it once again
but that first season i was writing the
last
you know the most important episodes of
the season you know practically which
were the last three episodes
working on that while we're shooting and
then
i'm flying back from new york to la to
edit
you know episode two which is gonna be
airing in two weeks
while i'm also writing and flying back
to new york to be on on set it was just
it that's not the way my brain works and
you know god bless
there are a lot of show runners uh that
that's how tv was traditionally done
that's what
some of some tv is still done uh it just
they can multitask like that i can't in
fact i went when i when i first started
because i yeah i never
sat put on a tv set before when i did mr
robot
and and and my wife emmy you know was on
shameless and
obviously john wells is a huge
showrunner and
done lots of great shows and i asked him
for advice and
you know he he was kind enough to sit me
down and
go through his day and it's like he
starts in the writers room and then
walks to set then goes to then ends with
at the edit and i just remember when he
first was explaining that to me i i was
just like i
i don't know if i can do that and
ultimately at the end of the first
season i said
you know i asked usa and again this is
why the
usa and ucp are so supportive because
they they immediately
said okay well if you need to get all
the scripts done before you start
shooting if that's your process
we'll stand behind you so that's what we
did
i actually think that your process of
having all the scripts done
is the way i would do it not that i
could do what you do
but i think it makes so much more sense
because then when you're shooting
you can block you can shoot when you're
at one location
you can shoot episode 1 6 7 and 10
while you're at that location so you're
saving time and money
by shooting everything like that and you
know
i i think it allows everyone to also
look at all the scripts the actors
and gauge their performance and through
the entire season
maybe i'm mistaken but yeah yeah no
that's
absolutely right from a production
standpoint it makes a lot of sense
because you can shoot out locations
uh like i remember in season two we were
in this beautiful
home for the uh uh for the um
smart house that uh that darlene her
character
and uh and f society take over and
that's across multiple episodes
and i remember such a pain in the ass to
load into this house because of the way
the house was constructed
but again gorgeous house but to to i
remember thinking
man if we were on the old way to go in
and out of that house
every week um even if it was like a one
three-page scene to just go in and shoot
anything to leave it and come back
just felt very inefficient and and and
kind of a
very uh much a waste of time so yeah
on that kind of efficient on that level
but it's more i got to be honest with
you it's more the thing that you said
about actors and
the mentality now there are challenges
because like i said we were shooting
scenes from the finale
first few days of production so that's
even though the actors all have the
all the scripts and know where they're
going they're having to track their arc
across 13 episodes
and then having to like jump into that
moment um so that proved to be
challenging too
um but i think ultimately everyone was
everyone was happier with the way the
the way that we shot because they they
always could you know not knowing i
think was always going to be a bigger
hurdle than that you know the not
knowing of where your character is going
to end up by the season
um are there easter eggs that people
have still not
found yes in really yes which surprises
me because we have such a great
community on reddit
there's one in particular obviously i'm
not going to share so don't bother
asking but
there's one in particular where i was a
little conf i was like were we not
obvious enough because i felt like it
was pretty blatant and no one got
it and you know again it it's not
relevant in terms of
the story it's not so let me just
explain
just that that it doesn't mean that
you're gonna miss out on
what the journey of elliot was or there
was but there was just an easter egg
that i thought was pretty blatant that i
thought would be fun
uh that was a fun reference that
connected to the themes of the show
but nobody i haven't i haven't heard
anybody get it
i will say i've been pretty busy so i
haven't checked the reddit page in a
while so
maybe someone's cracked it but i
remember when that series aired
i didn't i didn't notice anyone uh
figuring that one out
i i don't need you to say exactly where
it is because i know you're not going to
but can you say
what season four season i'm talking
about the last season
okay i'm just i'm just making sure so
there's definitely one
that people have not found are there
others from one two and three or most of
them have been found
i mean i you know every little one i i
doubt it
i mean you know i i and this is another
thing i
i really uh it was inspired by kubrick
he never wasted a moment to fill that
frame
with detail that attribute that
furthered the story or the theme
of what of what he was trying to say in
the movie
and that's that that's been my attitude
uh with mr robot and homecoming
everything i do
is i sit down the production designer
costume designer dp
and we look at every frame and it's just
like
what like i want more i want more i want
more i want i
what can we do with that no it can't
just be a pencil what does the pencil
mean
like i got crazy about it i got probably
a little too ocd about it
i got to say about so i would highly
doubt every one of those details
have been uncovered and again not that
it should this is
this is a story and this is a television
show it's not a crossword puzzle for
people
uh uh to to crack but um so i would
doubt that every little thing
uh was discovered but there was there
was probably the
biggest thing was probably that one for
uh that
from my memory at least that people that
i haven't heard people
figured out where did the idea for the f
society mask come from
um and how long did it take to figure
out the look of that mask it took
forever i worked with the production
designer in the first season
a long time um it actually came from i
i spoke with a a hacker that was part of
anonymous and i was
i was asking him how the viva v for
vendetta
mask came about and uh the story i got
i don't know i i you know you hear
multiple stories online so i don't know
if this is
i i i took his word for it but i i
couldn't confirm it but i loved the
story so much i ran with it
but the story i got was uh what if
uh or the story i got was is that they
basically needed they picked a mask
that was available worldwide
and that wasn't very expensive and that
be for
vendetta mask just happened to be a kind
of like a popular halloween mask or
something
that was available in most countries
around the world wasn't that expensive
and so that was the mask
anonymous chose to be their sort of
avatar for their
for their uh for their followers and so
um so i took that mentality and i said
okay well well if that society is going
to do that
uh what's what you know what's our sort
of pop culture reference
that they're going to use and that's
when i sort of came up with this little
horror film
that we show in season two but i was
thinking about in season one
um that ellie and darlene you know were
fans of and
um and then of course i you know it was
just fun to try and
invent what that villain was but tying
it to
the um the sort of the anti-corporate
uh themes of the show uh i i made a
little sort of a little bit of an
influence from the monopoly man a little
bit of an influence from v for vendetta
and then we sort of just went from there
i mean we had so many sketches
of it um because it had the uh it had to
be unique but at the same time you know
it had the
feel um because what's the word uh i had
to feel unsettling without being overt
and so i think that's what that that's
how you know because there are a lot
lot of early sketches were so overtly
creepy
that um that i i wasn't uh it was just
it became too cartoonish and so we we
had to dial it in and get the right sort
of level of
unsettling you know completely have you
walked around
before the pandemic did you ever walk
around comic-con wearing the f society
mask
no in fact i had not ever been to
comic-con
until homecoming and i was literally
there briefly
for my panel and then i had to leave um
because i was always working during
comic con
if i do i will bring the f society mask
uh i want to specifically talk about um
the camera placement
and how you guys decided on that when
you were directing
when you were writing the scripts were
you already visualizing
where the camera is going to be how
you're how you're shooting stuff
and how much was it you working with
your dp on set
you know after you're blocking the scene
okay now we're going to do this
so for sure filmmaking was a big factor
in the writers room because again i've
never looked at the writer's medium i
looked at it as a visual medium because
that's that is what it is
um and um and so that would became a big
part of how we
constructed episodes and stories in fact
that's how a lot of the format breaking
episodes were invented because
i would say well if the story we're
telling here is
elliot you know discovering
angela's betrayal at ecorp but at the
same time there's a protest outside and
angela ends up stealing so you know i
was like well
it feels like it's real time you know
we're writing this we're thinking of the
story the story comes first
but then i throw in well well it feels
like we're this story lasts
as long as the episode about 40-ish
minutes
so what's to say that we can't then
construct the episode as a single shot
and that so so the com one conversation
would
always lead to the other um or or even
like the
the the sort of the uh one of my
favorite episodes the sitcom
episode in in season two where um
where we again season two is all about
elliot's sort of internal
reckoning with uh with his disorder
well how does he escape well how does he
escape and we start throwing out ideas
from a filmmaking perspective that would
push that storyline which is
like he would escape because he grew up
watching sitcoms those are
that's where he went for comfort as a
little kid
and so uh and and then we came up with
that format and it always
informed the filmmaking and vice versa i
would always
uh i always whenever i throw it out in
the writers room
it would everyone get so excited because
i don't think that was a typical thing
that people would discuss in the
writer's room because it was
again really specifically uh all about
how to get from
point a to point b with the character
but not ha
sorry not how you're gonna film it or
how you're gonna put all that together
so that's that's sort of like the very
high level
you know so those decisions get made
then that early on
but then when you're talking about
production
what what i do is i i'd sit down taught
i mean i just did it just now
with the pilot um for acts of crime
and we go through the script in detail
and we both are coming to it with ideas
because you know he's obviously a very
visual person as am i
and as i'm writing i've got pictures in
my head and so does he
and so we just go through every scene
and we share those pictures
and then we sort of decide which one
which one feels more right or
is there a combination of the two or do
we throw both out and
start to figure uh uh figure out other
things
some scenes we get to and
just knowing because ultimately when we
get to set
it's going to be about the actors and
the performance i mean
i always say this but i think it's true
even as as as
as i think great as great as all my my
entire team is
from productions like costume design
cinematography even editorial and posts
and everything
um performances make everything i always
say that like you know a great
performance
in a shoddy production uh
is is probably still i would rather
watch
than the than the opposite of
a beautifully designed film with
terrible performances
i wouldn't be able to sit through but i
would sit through a great performance so
i always
i always say we're doing the leg work
and we get in there
we're doing the stuff that's around the
mantelpiece which is
the performance which is rami or carly
or
porsha or grace or christian
they need to do their thing and so
i learned i didn't i didn't have
actually comment taught me this my wife
taught me this
i would storyboard every little thing to
a t and then i'd get on set and i would
say okay emmy you're sitting here justin
you're sitting over there
and then on this line you get up and you
go over there i would just that
because i i had it all storyboard i
literally took
stills um with stand-ins just to
literally with blend sizes and
everything and then justin would say
well if i got up on this line instead
and went over to this corner that i had
you know i had not even thought i was
going to shoot in that corner
um and and emmy would do the same well i
don't feel like i would want to get up
and do x-ray
and it started it started to dawn on me
that
certain scenes you know it's pointless
to shot list and it would it would
actually hurt the movie
or the or the or that tv episode that
you're trying to
whatever the scene that you're trying to
work on if i went in there too prepared
so there are certain scenes where uh you
know
again we just did an actual crime where
we're like it's three people they're in
a room they're walking they're talking
there's chairs you know i don't know
what they're gonna do
um blocking and so we don't we don't
shot listed
we say let's go in on set we don't have
also the it's location dependent we
haven't found the location yet
let's go in let's see what the actors
want to do and then that's when todd and
i huddle afterwards
and say okay let's start putting a lens
up let's start figuring out how we're
going to tell this
and also sometimes they inform you know
when we when we start
thinking about how we're going to shoot
it we always go into it with a point of
view of a character
and sometimes i don't know what that is
until i see the actors perform it
and you know maybe i'm thinking it's
it's this character and then
i see the the rehearsal and i'm like no
i think it's that person over there
and i think the camera needs to be there
and it's a wonder i don't even need the
coverage of the other people
that happened a lot on homecoming where
we would say it's blocking to
depend there was one scene in particular
at the beginning of episode three
where um there was three characters two
of them were talking
one was silent watching the other two
talk
and so of course you assume you're gonna
block you know you get coverage of
everyone talking and
um and maybe you get a reaction shot and
then you you move on
but i watched the scene i watched the
rehearsal jeremy allen white was
also shameless uh was in the scene and i
was watching and the whole time during
the rehearsal i was watching jeremy and
i knew that the scene was about him and
how he
how he was feeling about what was going
on and so i said it's a wonder and we're
gonna move to jeremy and we're gonna
move out and then that's it and we
didn't even cover
uh the other character's dialogue
because that's what this that's what the
scene was about so
those kind of choices get made on set uh
and that happened a lot especially when
you work with such talented actors
you know on on robot you know they it's
a it's a joy sometimes to just
let be surprised and discover something
that you didn't even know about the
about your own material i'm curious how
budget played into
the writing process and what you
actually did
in each season like how much like let's
arbitrarily say and i know this is not
the right number
say you had a million dollars to make
the entire season
and you knew that was the budget so
you're in the writers room and as you're
writing
how much are you thinking well this is
going to cost us you know 200 000
so the next two episodes we kind of have
to like stay in
elliot's apartment do you know what i
mean like how does that factor in
knowing the budget for the show
i never let that factor in um the
scripts the that to me was a poison pill
in the writers room
i never and by the way they were you
know we would have writers in there that
were
that had been around in tv in the tv
world before and
um and that was all i always surprised i
was always in the back of their minds
well you know we can't do that scene
that's just going to be
so expensive and last we make the next
episode the bottle episode
and i just remember thinking to myself
how awful is that that you would let
that dictate
what kind of story you want to tell um
i to me it was always about let's tell
the best story
let's not infect the writer's room with
any of that
let's tell the let's tell the best story
and when we get into production
what's going to end up happening is
someone's going to tell me and it
happened every season
this is too much money this is going to
take forever
and then i would i would pick and choose
and say
okay so across the entire season we know
these things are important
these things are maybe second tier i'd
take it back to the writer's room at
that point and say
we may have to just streamline or
consolidate these scenes
um what and then that because because
you know there is a
there is a value in the thought of you
know if you don't have money that can
get
you some sometimes great things can come
out of that which is true
but i never just so that was always like
an afterthought i was like let me bring
it back
and now you know we know that we want
these high level things i'm glad we
went you know went uh uh went haywire
and figured all that out
but now like these sort of second tier
things can we find a way to streamline
or get
get them from point a to point w b
sometimes we just make cuts
because again run time and every we you
know run time would
sometimes be an issue so we would just
make cuts and that would save us money
so it was
always like an after managerial after
thought
but to start off thinking that way i
always just felt
was always a mistake um i would imagine
there were a lot of deleted scenes along
the way
yeah are there certain scenes that you
really wish
would be added back into the episodes
because now that it's on streaming
and you know now that it's not on
broadcast was everything
no no everything you know again because
i had such great partners
there was nothing cut where i was like
we have to
keep this run time i mean if you look at
the episodes some of them were
an hour over an hour some of them were
40 minutes usa
again uh such such great supporters of
ours that
they were they really let us let us do
our thing
we were we were more
i would say i was very hard on us in
terms of
let's make sure things are tight when we
when uh
you know let's be hard on ourselves
about that you know i'm very much about
getting the pacing and the rhythm right
which sometimes
doesn't have anything to do with the run
time right um yeah
an episode could feel very fast but be
60 minutes long
that's why this whole sort of uproar
about run time
always felt silly to me like the number
like you know i'd hear people on twitter
uh complaining they're like uh oh
another 62-minute slog
you haven't even started the [ __ ]
episode you could watch that it could be
great
i mean one of my favorite series one of
the years it's a donkey series with o.j
made in america
i think every episode was 90 minutes
long and i loved every
second of it um and so when it when it's
good it's good when it's working
it's working um you don't need to
arbitrarily say
so it needs to be a certain time you
know that that's stuff we
we put we we sort of uh put to the
sidelines so
um yeah i don't know if i answer about
ear question i think i did
you did i'm always curious with the
hacking one of the things that the show
is always talked about and one of the
things that everyone agrees on is the
hacking depicted in mr robot is
accurate and it you know it's not just
like somebody typing in
20 keys and they've broken into the nsa
you know what i mean it's like
it's realistic but so you're in the
writers room
and when you're coming up with ideas
like say the script like whatever the
episode is about
at some point elliott has to do
something to you know get into something
how was it in the writer's room in terms
of
like in the writer's room are you like
elliot hacked like this is the steamer
elliott hacks and then you hand it
to like the people who know what they're
doing with hacking and they're helping
you like how was how were those scenes
written no because because that was so
important to me
because that's what i thought failed so
much in in in prior films and and and tv
shows
when they when they tried to address
hacking i
made sure that we had and you know first
fourth season's
first three seasons we had a great
producer
cora donna in the room and then in the
last season roxanne was in the room
um and they were part of their
they were writers they were part of the
storytellers uh they were part of the
storytelling team so it was not just
fill in the blank
it was okay elliott needs to pull this
off and that was the other thing
we didn't um look through the newspaper
and say
what kind of hacks should we make elliot
do this episode
it was never about that it was well
eliot is a character
and we got to treat him like a person
and he's trying to do x or trying to get
y or someone's in the way
or whatever what's he going to do with
his strength
and then that's when core or roxanne
would chime in
and offer ideas and and then
you know because it's not that
it's really it's not really about a guy
on a keyboard
it's really about more about the social
engineering
aspect of it about how to you know
manipulate people
and fish people so it when you take that
into consideration
it it moves our story it's exciting for
us as
writers who are not you know tech savvy
at all
to then find that social engineering
as an interesting new drama and an
interesting new
dramatic conflict to to throw into the
story and that will sometimes
inform what happens after the hack
how does elliot get out of it or how
does he form a new relationship because
of it
you know those kind of things so it was
very much ingrained it was not something
that
um that we just sort of bracketed and
threw it out
it was definitely a big part of how we
of what we wanted to tell the story for
every episode
i'm assuming while making this series
you learned an awfully lot
about the way computers operate and the
behind the scenes of
networking and hacking and all that
stuff
how has making this show possibly
impacted the way you
operate online personally or the way you
interact with certain things have you
learned certain lessons you're like
you know i will never click on something
that i have never
heard of or do you know what i mean yeah
no i i i will say i've been paranoid
prior to robot i i remain paranoid in
fact i'm shocked that people aren't more
paranoid
um you know i i i feel like
the biggest issue right now online is
privacy
no one seems to care about that that
much
um they sign up for all these free
services that steal all your data
and are manipulating them in in ways
that they don't even understand
um and so i'm a very very uh i've been a
i will say but prior the robot i was
one of the one of the reasons why i
probably was fascinated about even
telling the story about
uh hackers is that they seem to got they
seem to get that
that there that there's this sort of
nefarious thing happening
online with data and protection and
privacy
and um and and how vulnerable people are
leaving themselves
uh with the the behavior with the their
online behavior so
um i didn't really change that much i i
probably got more paranoid as the years
went on but
not necessarily because of the show just
that it's you know as
as you look around at the world just
it's a lot more dangerous on the
especially with social media
one of the other things that i uh loved
about the series is the way it tackled
mental health
which is something that not a lot of for
some reason it's still
a third rail with most shows and it's
just something that people
are so hesitant to talk about i do feel
like in the last few years it's gotten
easier to talk about
more people are coming forward and
saying something i deal with
you know such and such but what do you
think it is did
is that something that you noticed a lot
of people wanting to talk to you about
the way
you tackle mental health in the series
and have you noticed
like maybe it's becoming easier to get
into movies or tv or
become part of a storyline yeah well
a i will say that i think when the
the sort of deeper connections i feel
with fans are the ones
that are suffering from mental uh uh
from some sort of mental
uh health issue i suffer from social
anxiety disorder
um i also was diagnosed with obsessive
compulsive disorder early on
a lot of people did reach out a lot of
fans
who had that connection to reach people
on a level like that
really really i i felt that was
profoundly moving um i think
i put it in the bracket of
you know storytelling is just opening up
in in great ways because these
taboos and you know diversity is like
another
uh uh uh topic that
you know back in the day it was
straight white men were your heroes
and they never had a mental illness or
mental health issue god forbid
that was a weirdo sidekick you know um
or they would have their black friend or
uh uh or they're they're they're they're
they're a funny indian friend but it was
never
uh the the the general consensus was
that the main character
typically was this white straight male
and without mental
health a mental health issue and when it
was
used a lot of times it could come off
very gimmicky
for the sake of some sort of plot
machination and obviously you can accuse
mr robot of that as well because we
really delve into his mental it becomes
an essential fabric of the show and it
is part
largely part of the plot as well but
i think we didn't also pull punches with
it
elliot as a character warts and all
suffered from a a serious mental illness
um even though it affected and impacted
the way we told the story
and uh and the way we uh uh
created certain reveals and certain
moves within the plot
we still showed and hopefully that was
at least our intent was to show in a
really honest
and vulnerable way how people can suffer
from mental illness
and i think you know partly i think it's
story
so storytelling in general has sort of
evolved in
a lot of ways where people are starting
to recognize there are more stories to
tell
outside of the the white straight male
uh uh prototype um that that's very
exciting and it can connect with people
but the other thing is is i i i
attribute a lot of this to tech
i do think mental illness is also on the
rise and i
again i fault i felt technology i i know
that there's a
a kind of a connection between the two
um
but i do think unfortunately that is on
the rise and
and so uh in a in a weird kind of way
that
that's probably a larger part of the
reason why it's it's a conversation now
or it's in the public
and in the sort of public square because
um i think more people are starting to
recognize
that uh that that they do have a a a a
problem or an issue that they can't
quite understand or explain
and are afraid to talk about it with
other people
and when they watch a show like this it
there's a connection there that they can
make
i want to touch on episode 407 which is
the
episode for people that are watching uh
where it's
all in the in gloria's um
i guess it's condo apartment i don't
know what the right term is i would say
apartment
yeah um but it's it's such a tremendous
episode
and i'm curious if you could talk about
like how that episode came about in
terms of the writer's room
how you figured out it was just going to
be this one location and how
so much was going to be sort of revealed
in that
episode well so that was a big reveal
that i held on to
for a long time um
and i always that was like one of the
things that i always knew we had to
build up to
uh and when we started talking about
that episode
uh it we were the story line
was going to be that you know elliott uh
elliott was with
and you know trapped in chris's
apartment with vera
and i think we were cutting with that
cutting from that
to the story line with darlene um
and dom uh uh in
uh
angela's apartment um and
it always felt i mean i think it wasn't
just me but i remember just voicing it
this feels
wrong you know with such a big reveal
to cut outside of that story line the
the elliott storyline
i really felt like we needed to stay
with him
throughout the whole journey because it
needed to grow within us the way the
realization
of what was happening or what was going
on needed to sort of
grow within uh within us the way it grew
within elliot
i mean the way when we would talk to our
psychologist
consultant who has been us been with us
since the beginning
since the pilot um
she you know she talks about how those
sort of breakthroughs happen
and it's a it's like a sort of it's like
a sunrise almost it
dawns on them in a in a very slow way
but then at a certain point
it just accelerates and comes out in
this
really cathartic uh uh
breakdown or outpouring um
and i felt like the episode needed to
reflect
that and so i was like i think we got to
stay
in that room the whole time and i think
it needs to be real time
uh like like four like uh 305
it needs to be real time we need to be
with him
through every beat and we need to be
with elliot for every beat
and and i really want the audience to uh
to to to to really really uh
be on the level with elliot um
and and and and and honestly
because you know when we when we kind of
made the decision it needed to be real
time
you know i knew that i didn't want a
single take or anything like that
but i i just remember feeling the sense
of
it needs to be them it needs to be about
them
i actually wa as a filmmaker kind of
wanted to disappear
i just said i just i just i i wa
this is a and that's when i started to
say it's a play
it's a play it's not it can't i don't
want to think about the cameras
necessarily
it really is a play it really is about
the actors
you know what i was saying earlier the
performance is the mantle piece well
it no more it couldn't be any truer than
in this episode
it had to be about the performances and
i had to get the
[ __ ] out of the way the only way this
was going to work
was if people were watching them and not
paying any attention
to what i'm doing and so when i kept
saying it was it was like a play
it then we said wait a minute why are we
why are we like dancing around this
let's just call it what it is it's a
five-act play
we're gonna go through the stages where
we
whereby elliott comes to this
realization about himself
and we're gonna we're gonna stand out of
we're gonna
step aside and let the the
the professionals take over let these
masterful actors that we've
that were in that scene just go with it
and
um and so the the second decision i made
when i after i made the decision that it
was uh going to be like this five act
play
is i said you know you know when you
shoot
just just really quick when you shoot
you typically you shoot one side of the
conversation
you know someone's reading offline and
then you finish up
and you do some takes and then you turn
around you do the other side
you know um i i was like i i
would i don't i don't think i can ask
these
actors to perform this off camera
that that hurt me inside it really did
pain me to think about that
because because it i'm asking him to go
to some really
really tough places and really um and
really
get there and stay there and so uh the
second
decision i made which is again crazy
decision that usa and ucp somehow
allowed me to do and supported me with
is
i brought in eight cameras and
it was filmed like a play and there was
there was we would do an act at a time
and there was coverage on everybody
going on at the same time the cameras
were
we literally put punched holes in the
walls and
stuck in cameras where we could and i
was
literally staying in a video village
with eight monitors and
i was having to tell this camera to move
over there to get
that person's coverage and move over
here okay now for this you know moment
get over there
but the idea was is that i wanted to get
out of the actors away i wanted them to
do their thing and um
and i didn't want them to repeat it or
do anything off camera i wanted
everything to be feel
live and i wanted every everyone to feel
like they're always connecting because
you know oftentimes when your actors are
off camera
they're looking over a shoulder they're
looking you know they're they're next to
a camera guy
delivering these really intense dramatic
lines
and so all of that i made sure was taken
away
and it was the real focus was just on
uh just on the actors and we shot it in
five days
an act a day we came in we
rehearsed the one act the the act
whatever act we were going to do that
day
and then i would send them away and do i
would do a rehearsal with the camera and
make sure all our
movement again we're eight camera
operators this is this is just
you just don't do this on on a show like
this
and um and again it was like one of
those things where everyone felt like we
were doing something special
and everyone just put their heads down
and just
knocked it out and i yeah i mean i give
a lot of credit to
the crew those days were rough because
every you know imagine eight cameras in
each other's way
trying on a cr there's one on a crane
there's people on
dollies um and and they're having to
really choreograph and be in sync so
they don't run into each other
as we're capturing all of this um but i
just felt like
the performance here was was was what
mattered and
and we needed to get out of the way as
much as possible
well that's one of those uh episodes
where the camera works great
the direction's great the performances
are great the dialogue is great
it's one of those where like it all just
comes together you know the
everything but i i am curious when
you're writing an episode like that
because it's
finally pulling back a real reveal that
you've been holding on to for a while
how long did it actually take to write
that episode with all the monologues and
all the dialogue that people are talking
about
was it one that like you guys kind of
worked on
longer than some of the other episodes
no it was like
in the room we kind of got the major
beats down
of what each act was about but because
it was mostly dialogue
it wasn't something we really could work
on in the room very much
uh you know it took a while to figure
out how we progressed
to the reveal and so the larger beats
had to be really nailed down
but honestly it was one of the quicker
ones because
there weren't a lot of plot machinations
or plot movements
it was all about the dialogue
and and uh and um the sort of
larger purpose of each act um
and then i took that and um i remember i
think
i was going away for christmas
um you know we had like a two-week break
and emmy and i
uh i think we were you know i don't know
we were going somewhere
and as a long flight is all i remember i
think it was like a 12-hour flight and i
can't sleep on planes
emmy she can sleep she's totally
she can sleep anywhere she was asleep
and uh
i uh i wrote the whole draft on that
flight and of course then i
get there and i'm in the darkest
place in my life you know i'm just like
this whole thing came out of me but
it felt good in that sense but in the
other sense i was like
man i shouldn't have just written that
right before this two-week
trip than trying to spend with my wife
here um
but uh but that also felt cathartic i
got to say
and and my god scary obviously it sounds
like your relationship with usa when you
were making this series was incredible
and they were incredibly supportive of
you know putting the show on the air and
giving you the artistic freedom to do
what you wanted to do
saying that i'm assuming there's always
a battle over something
behind the scenes or was there not a
battle on this can you
do you remember any battles that you
guys actually sort of bat
like fought over even if it was minor or
was it always very amicable
i mean think about the episode we just
talked about
you know to me i was expecting that when
i
revealed that this is what's happening
that they were going to say no i mean
this is just a bridge too far
it is it you know to anthony's point and
to
everybody out there who who may have not
loved that episode
it it can come off as exploitive and we
were talking about an incredibly
sensitive
topic that touches a lot of lives in
this in this country in the world
and they didn't blink usa didn't blink
they told me they supported me i can't
think of better partners
how much they've supported me and and
all the big swings we
we've taken on in the show including
you know uh tackling an incredibly
serious
uh topic like that so um
yeah i don't have any uh any dramatic
stories for you
uh they they were they were they were
always on my side
no i mean it sounds to me like you guys
had one of those very rare
amazing relationships i mean let me let
me tell you how amazing it was
the executive they worked with close
closely was alex seppiel and
mr robot fans would know that i named
elliot's alter ego
in the show sam me sepia
that's how close i i i i was with
usa that's how that's how supportive
they were that's how much i respected
them is that
they became the alter ego of our main
character in the show
i could be wrong about this and i
apologize if i don't know this
did you guys ever release like a big
blu-ray box set
or are there any plans for doing any
sort of special home video release for
the series
so here's what i'll say because i i've
seen this on a lot on social media
there is a box of the complete series
it's blu-ray it's hd
it's 1080p i get a lot of questions
about 4k release
i will say this now it's unfortunate and
sad but we never finished the show in 4k
because surprise surprise 4k is a lot
more expensive to finish than 1080p
uh so so there is no 4k version
of the show obviously we shot everything
where if we could uprise it to 4k i
would at some point
love to do that um but you guys are
gonna have to
tweet at usa you can't tweet at me i i
don't have the power to do that